figured i'd show this to you
because it's very easy to see where i've
had the chicken tractor with the rabbits
in it
um every time i plant anything
it's in some sort of a raised bed so
i've got a spiral herb garden which
technically is a raised bed
on the other side of that is my orchard
which everything is in race beds
in my garden everything's in raised beds
and matter of fact the fruit trees that
are back there
and all of the berries are also all in
raised beds
and a lot of people keep asking me why i
keep spending money on this soil that
i'm unloading
out of my truck sitting there and with
the ground
for the grass being so small
now i can show you why now one of the
things you got to keep in mind
is it rained this week so the cracks are
actually smaller
but there's this one right here
which is indicative of clay soil
this stuff is hard as a rock like you
you just couldn't be
you just can't dig it up
see that do i have a knife i have a
knife
which what am i carrying today victoria
knox
let's see we'll just use the end of it
there of course it breaks it up
but you got to use some force this is
really hard clay soil
and these cracks will get so big that i
can literally
do my fingers like this and stick my
whole hand into the ground
so they'll get an inch and a half wide
the reason why they're so small right
now
is because it rained earlier this week
several inches of rain as a matter of
fact
and let me show you something else the
rabbits start digging
and if you got rabbits you know how
sharp their claws are they just give up
they they dig a little bit and they just
give up because
they know the ground's just too hard for
them to do anything
in so
that is why i have to go
and keep buying soil now
i would prefer to be able to buy the
soil in bulk
the problem is i can't find any bulk
places around here to buy soil
or compost mix or you know a soil
compost mix or something like that
so i have to keep just going and buying
bag soil
and then it takes about a year for
the sterile soil there's another place
where rabbits tried to dig and they dug
down a little farther there
and this is mostly a shaded area so the
ground was probably a little softer
there and i still gave up
but what i was getting at is
the sterile soil you buy from a store
takes about a year to acclimate to your
soil
for all the beneficial microbes to move
up into it
for you to add nutrients to it it takes
about a year
and uh that's actually why that you
see people that build raised beds and
use store-bought soil why their gardens
usually don't do
very good the first year it's because
all the
beneficial microbes are missing from the
soil but anyways
this is just a quick video i wanted to
show you
why i buy bag soil and kind of go over
that
and i'll go ahead and let you uh watch
me
unload the last half of the soil
when working outside when it's 95
degrees always make sure you got a
bottle of water out of the refrigerator
you